[Risate]
[Musica]
e questo ci mancava pure la cosa
gelato e l'altro al cioccolato patatine
flash
tutto negando
[Musica]
no
ai loro più berlino
[Musica]
[Risate]
mettiti difendere il tuo padrone
devo trasformando così un lupo bucate
una siena aiuto mamma mia che paura
guarda guarda c'è la luna piena allora
mi mandarono devi devi obbedire alla
luna vi era come si dice non lo so c'è
nessuna pietà e ancora il giorno o no è
vero il coraggio per notte troppi soldi
ci sto chiuderà la porta ma che cosa è
successo mi sono addormentato alita si è
trasformata cosa devo fare adesso non lo
so l'idea forse ne posso parlare
riuscirà a capire se le scrivo che c'è
qualcosa che non va in lei sì le parlerò
ma è visto che strano
aveva un occhio da lupo è un occhio da
umano che imita scusami siete o chiusa
fuori ma avevo paura che mi sbagliassi
adesso freno alla porta e mi raccomando
non sbranare
poi possiamo parlare in fondo va bene
sto per aprire la porta
[Musica]
piano piano la voglio solo parlarsi in
fondo
[Musica]
ok il processo cassa certi assaggiarli
io sono buono
lo scopriremo molto presto aspetta
aspetta
vieni qua parliamone ti devo spiegare
nelle cose prima che gli enti fiera
delle cose sono i segni la vera vita
c'è una maledizione su di te ti sta
trasformando lentamente il lupo quindi
non pensare che sono il lupo tu non mi
vuoi mangiare che ti ricordi che siamo
fidanzati non mi vorrai mica a mangiare
poi guarda non bayern che cosa c'è
perché mi stai guardando così immediato
che ho sbagliato io in realtà vogliono
mangiare perché vorresti mai a fare una
cosa del genere che potresti essere
molto buone da mangiare non sono buona
da mangiare guarda poi sono pieno di
peli potrei essere un lupo mannaro non
sono assolutamente buono da mangiare
anzi guarda con tutte quelle cose che ma
non potrei anche essere velenoso magari
male dopo è qualcosa che non va 20 no
meglio non mangiare l'italia beh va beh
allora ci fosse una camera sia penso
perché così potrai trasformare la prova
qui quando già tanti che vista la
qualità è venuta un'idea andrò a
chiedere consiglio a qualcuno
sicuramente mi saprà aiutare le sta qui
macrino stai attento resta qui vero
[Musica]
perfino o no la porta aperta manita cosa
facciamo adesso berlino la vita è
scappata sarebbe essersi nascosta in
qualsiasi parte in questa casa bernino
avvisami se per caso senti l'odore di
anita qui in giro da qualche parte e
questo cos'è patatine aspetta un attimo
sembra ci siano delle tracce qui faccio
di patatine
vediamo dove portano wow che fortuna ho
trovato un sentiero di patatine che mi
porta ad una busta di patatine proprio
per me wow
allora adesso mi metto proprio qui e
mele maggio c'è qualcuno che mi vuole
bene
non è noto non lo puoi mandare a madrid
e paolo porta
bravo
[Musica]
che strano mi sento mi è sembrato di
sentire comune
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta non sei
del tutto trasformata sei ancora anita
non sei un lupo mannaro
quindi tu non vuoi mordermi tu non puoi
mangiarne c'è ancora delbono inter non
sei un lupo mannaro
io devo fermare la trasformazione e devo
fermarla prima che arrivi la luna piena
che mi credi ciao e che è troppo tardi
[Musica]
o no tra poco la vita si trasformerà in
un completo lupo mannaro
tutto procede secondo i piani colora
[Musica]